vor kurzem haben wir eine nachricht von
unserem pen mitglied amy bekommen und
amy hat folgendes geschrieben hallo ich
hätte gern ein video über das wort
beziehungsweise es wird oft verwendet
und ich verstehe es wenn ich es höre
aber ich habe kein gefühl dafür wann ich
es verwenden soll
und genau darum geht es in diesem video
wir stellen euch heute mal das wort
beziehungsweise vor
los geht's
ok fangen wir mal an mit der aussprache
beziehungsweise ist ein langes wort und
daher auch vielleicht nicht so ganz
natürlich zum anwenden für leute die
gerade deutsch lernen bcs weise kann man
sogar der vogel hat mit gerät im
richtigen takt beziehungsweise was ganz
populär ist es auch die abkürzung bzw
das lest ihr vielleicht häufiger mal in
einem geschriebenen text und jetzt gehen
wir auch schon zur bedeutung bevor wir
euch die offizielle bedeutung des dudens
vorstellen möchte janisch euch etwas
erzählen er hatten wir nämlich gerade
gesagt dass man beziehungsweise auch
ziemlich wörtlich verstehen kann
deshalb lade ich jetzt mal die amish vor
die kamera ein und er versucht das in
ganz einfachen worten zu beschreiben
beziehung bedeutet auch einfach ein
verhältnis zu einer situation oder zu
ein ding das heißt wenn du sagst
beziehungsweise heißt das ähnlich wie in
ein verhältnis dazu wie in einen anderen
verhältnis das heißt wir verstehen ein
ding und eine situation so in einem
gewissen verhältnis zu dem ding wenn
mein verhältnis zu dem ding kann das ist
verändert sich direkt auch das
verständnis von diesem ding also bzw
in einem anderen möglichen verhältnis
würde das vielleicht anders aussehen
kommen wir jetzt zur offiziellen
bedeutung der duden schreibt als erste
bedeutung für beziehungsweise oder und
genauer gesagt man benutzt also bzw
immer dann wenn man etwas präzisieren
will wenn man eine andere möglichkeit
nennen will
oder manchmal auch wenn man etwas
korrigieren will
hier seht ihr mal ein beispiel wo wir
sind jetzt hier schon an einem platz den
ich sehr sehr gerne mag beziehungsweise
ein gebiet
das ist der grüngürtel der sich um teile
der kölner innenstadt steht in diesem
beispiel hatte sie gesagt wir sind jetzt
hier an einem platz den ich sehr gerne
mag beziehungsweise ein gebiet sie
könnte auch sagen oder eigentlich ein
gebiet also eigentlich in diesem fall
korrigiert sie sich so ein bisschen sie
hat gesagt das ist ein platz
dann ist sie ausgefallen platz ist
vielleicht nicht das richtige wort
um das zu beschreiben was sie
beschreiben will und dann sagt sie
beziehungsweise gebiet denn das was sie
meinte es nicht nur ein platz sonne ein
gebiet sie sagt also ich zeige dass noch
mal so wir sind jetzt hier schon an
einem platz den ich sehr sehr gerne mag
beziehungsweise ein gebiet man könnte
also hier auch sagen wir sind hier an
einem platz oder eigentlich einem gebiet
dieses beziehungsweise könnte man also
ersetzen mit oder oder oder eigentlich
und es ist auch insgesamt eine sehr
populäre stadt in deutschland und zur
folge einer umfrage aus dem jahr 2018
sogar die populärste stadt bzw das
populärste bundesland in unserem dritten
beispiel stelle ich die bundesländer vor
und ich rede hier über hamburg hamburg
ist gleichzeitig eine stadt und ein
bundesland und ich erzähle davon das ist
ein ranking gibt in dem hamburg die
populärste stadt beziehungsweise das
populärste bundesland ist und hier kann
man bzw auch ersetzen mit oder
eigentlich also eigentlich will ich mich
hier korrigieren
denn dieses ranking über das ich spreche
listet die beliebtesten bundesländer
nicht die beliebtesten städte in
deutschland also sage ich
hamburg ist auch als beliebteste stadt
bekannt beziehungsweise als beliebtestes
bundesland also eigentlich korrigiere
ich mich hier selber und vielleicht ist
das auch ein guter tipp dass man
beziehungsweise dann benutzt wenn man
einfach ein anderes
eine andere alternative nennen möchte
oder vielleicht etwas präzisieren oder
korrigieren möchte übrigens wenn ihr
noch andere interessante deutsche
vokabeln kennenlernen möchten dann ladet
euch doch mal unsere apps herunter
siedlung gibt es im app store und im
google places und dort stellen wir euch
unter anderem die 6.000 wichtigsten
deutschen vokabeln vor
und dort findet ihr zu jeder vokabel
auch eine übersetzung in verschiedenen
sprachen und beispielsätze und viele
übungen die zweite bedeutung von
beziehungsweise die der duden nennt
kommt nicht so häufig vor wie die erste
und die zweite bedeutung ist und in
einem anderen fall
das heißt diese zweite bedeutung von
beziehungsweise dann nennt man nicht
eine andere alternative oder man
präzisiert nicht das gleiche noch mal in
einem anderen wort sondern man nennt
eigentlich zwei verschiedene sachen
nacheinander
ich gebe euch mein beispiel dessen
dieses beispiel dass auch aus dem duden
man könnte sagen ich habe zwei kinder
und meine kinder sind vier
beziehungsweise sechs jahre alt das
heißt hier spreche ich von zwei kindern
und ich präzisiere nicht die zahlen ich
korrigiere mich nicht mit der zahl
sondern ich habe tatsächlich zwei
verschiedene zahlen die ich nennen
möchte und liste die nacheinander auf
ich könnte also sagen meine kinder sind
vier und sechs jahre alt also hier ist
dieses beziehungsweise sowie und so ich
hoffe diese erklärung war jetzt nicht zu
schwierig und ich hoffe unsere unserer
zuschauerin amy hat dieses video auch
geholfen du kannst uns ja mal einen
kommentar schreiben
tatsächlich ist das wort bzw einfach zu
verstehen wenn du es selber anwenden
möchtest dann würde ich es tatsächlich
dann am ehesten anwenden wenn du etwas
selber präzisieren oder korrigieren
möchtest wenn du vielleicht ein wort
benutzt hast das war so ungefähr
richtig aber dann fällt ihr noch ein
besseres wort ein
dann kannst du bzw sagen habt ihr noch
andere wörter die ihr auch schwierig
findet im deutschen entweder weil sie
viele verschiedene bedeutungen haben
oder weil sie schwierig sind in der
verwendung schreibt uns gerne einen
kommentar und wir machen gerne solche
videos wo wir einzelne wörter in einem
ganzen video erklären wenn ihr mehr
vokabeln lernen wollt in deutschen dann
schaut euch auch unbedingt unsere app
siedlung an die könnt ihr jetzt
herunterladen
im app store und im google place tor und
dort die 6.000 wichtigsten vokabeln die
grammatik und vieles mehr üben danke
fürs sehen und bis bald
[Musik]